et pour louis aliot député rnd
pyrénées-orientales la commission
denquête dois tu entends des différents
témoignages pour comprendre les
dysfonctionnements en france lors de
cette pandémie
j'espère en tout cas qu'elle sera pleine
de vérité est que les uns et les autres
auront la décence de dire ce qu'ils ont
vécu les documents qu'ils ont dans leur
procession pour que la commission puisse
avoir une vision claire du processus
une vision de claire je veux dire du
calendrier et une vision claire des
désordres qui ont été donné des
consignes qui ont été passés tout cela
est important pour bien comprendre les
dysfonctionnements qui ont
malheureusement démontré que la france
n'avait pas de masque n'avait pas de
respirateur n'avait pas de gel hydro
alcoolique a mis en péril son personnel
soignant et a été obligé j'allais dire
dans l'urgence de confiner tout un pays
parce que simplement elle n'avait pas
les moyens de protéger sa population
donc j'espère que ça ira jusqu'au bout